nerve stars Emma Roberts and Dave Franco
and is a movie about an online game
called nerve in which you can dare
people to do something increasingly more
dangerous you can be a watcher or you
can be a player the Dare start out
smaller and get increasingly more
dangerous as they go along and when
these two characters run into each other
in the middle of the city the Watchers
of the game want them to team up to play
but things get really messy when the
Dare start to get close to breaking the
law and that's where the movie gets
interesting this was a surprisingly
entertaining movie I had very low
expectations going in but I really liked
the charisma of the stars emma roberts
and dave franco worked really well
together their characters weren't very
interesting there were attempts to make
them interesting by giving them small
backstories every once in a while
littered throughout the movie but it was
mostly their charisma together that made
the movie fun to watch it's also a very
fast paced movie it's a neon drenched
film almost every scene has a neon light
of some kind it's a very good looking
movie it's very tightly edited it's very
fast paced and I think most people who
go to this movie just wanting to watch a
fun disposable thriller that will
entertain them for 90 minutes they're
going to get that with one specific
caveat though if you give this movie a
moment's thought it really doesn't make
sense this is absolutely a movie that
you have to suspend disbelief if you
even think for a second about this movie
you start to notice all these plot holes
and inconsistencies and things that just
don't make sense and one of the biggest
ones for me is that this is a game where
thousands of people are watching people
dared to do things and eventually we get
into law-breaking territory now these
are thousands of people who are filming
and documenting these events it also
talks about tragedies that occurred last
year in which people were killed so when
you start thinking about that it's easy
to connect the dots and be like why
aren't the authorities shutting this
game down I mean the IRS can go after
sites that have torrents of movies and
music a game where people are dying and
thousands are watching and filming it
seems a little hard to believe a movie
that went for a similar scenario was
David Fincher's the game starring
Michael Douglas and it did it in a much
better way the movie also has a
soundtrack that for me was very 5050
sometimes I really like the electronic
pulsating beats the soundtrack had but
then there were other scenes where it
was very much so this music tells you
how to feel feel this way
right now tons of montages where the
music would be sad and now we're
supposed to feel sad or the music would
be really upbeat and our supposed to
feel upbeat instead of the characters
and the dialogue allowing us to feel
this way it was very much so soundtrack
telling us how to feel and that happens
a lot in movies like this and it's not
really that big of an issue I think most
people will totally look past that but
from a filmmaking standpoint the music
is very aggressive in this movie and
it's almost a character in its own right
my biggest issue with this movie though
I can't really get into unless I warned
you about spoilers so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to grade this movie and
then I'm going to tell you what my
biggest issue with this film is and if
you haven't seen it yet or you don't
care then you can know I'm going to give
nerv a b-minus
ok so spoiler warning because this
movies been out for a few days and it's
one of those things where I have to
discuss it because it is my biggest
issue with this movie but it is a
spoiler so spoiler warning here we go my
biggest issue with nerve is the lack of
resolution
there isn't much finality at all the
movie ends very abruptly with so many
story arcs hanging in midair and you
never actually find out who's behind
this game and there's no real
consequences given to the people who are
the perpetrators who are committing a
lot of these crimes it just ends and I
guess we're supposed to be happy because
the two characters are now making out or
whatever and that's cool that they're
together but it's just I wanted some
finality but there's also another side
to that coin and that is that a lot of
times on the internet when people commit
crimes they stay hidden very well
because of how anonymous it is still
it's hard to believe because thousands
are watching and filming these events so
I wanted some consequences I wanted some
finality I wanted some sort of
resolution it felt very abrupt the way
it ended so those are my thoughts on
nerve perfectly entertaining watchable
movie with two good leads and I think
most people will probably really enjoy
it even though it takes a lot of
suspension of disbelief also I want to
let you guys know real quick that I am
still running my promotion with
crunchyroll.com if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman
this is the best anime streaming service
available as you guys know I am a huge
supporter of anime I love anime I've
always tried to support it and bring
more notice to it and crunchyroll is
doing a far better job than I am if you
go to crunchyroll.com slash Chris
Stockman you can try their premium
service for
free for 30-days you can watch all of
the anime available on their site for
free that's my gift to you guys and
crunchyroll thank you very much for
continuing to support my videos and
sponsor them it means a lot to me so go
to crunchyroll.com slash chris Duckman
you can try it for free for 30 days
that's my gift to you guys thank you so
much as always for watching and stay
tuned this Sunday because I'm starting
my series of Harry Potter reviews with
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone I
can't wait to talk about all those
movies big Harry Potter fans that's
going to be fun thank you once again for
watching I greatly appreciate it and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes